y
[Música]
día histórico para la democracia chilena
los ciudadanos votan este domingo en un
plebiscito para decidir si cambian o no
la constitución heredada de la dictadura
de augusto pinochet de aprobarse la
elección de los constituyentes se
realizaría en abril y la nueva
constitución se ratificaría en un nuevo
plebiscito
los candidatos a la presidencia de eeuu
intensifican sus campañas a 9 días de
las elecciones el presidente donald
trump votó de manera anticipada en
florida y visitó tres estados clave
mientras que el ex presidente barack
obama estuvo de miami para apoyar al
candidato demócrata joe biden
el líder opositor venezolano leopoldo
lópez llegaría a españa donde se
encontrara con su esposa e hijos un
vigilante privado de la embajada de
españa en caracas donde lópez se
encontraba refugiado hace un año y una
empleada del opositor fueron arrestados
mientras que el sebin comenzó un
registro de viviendas en las que reside
personal diplomático
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se revelan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en chile donde ya abrieron
las urnas en una votación histórica se
trata del plebiscito para determinar si
continúan rigiéndose o no por la carta
magna que heredaron de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet unos 15 millones de
chilenos están habilitados para votar y
son unos conteos de nueva zelanda y
australia el cip se ha llevado la gran
mayoría de los votos para analizar qué
impacto tiene este plebiscito quiero
saludar en este momento a paulina astros
ahí es abogada doctora en ciencias
políticas y sociales abogada buen día
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 le pregunto la importancia de
este plebiscito en chile en un contexto
de protestas y también descontento
social además le pregunto qué votarían
exactamente los chilenos el día de hoy
como estas buenos dias raúl la
importancia es máxima estamos hablando
de el dar la posibilidad dentro de un
sistema democrático a la ciudadanía a
expresarse si es que quiero no cambiar
la actual constitución que nos rige y
además el eje
cuál sería el órgano encargado en caso
de ganar el apruebo y que estaría
dedicado durante al menos nueve meses
con posee que la prórroga de tres veces
más es decir un año en redactar el nuevo
texto constitucional por lo tanto es un
hecho histórico el último plebiscito que
nosotros vivimos fue en 1988 cuando se
le dijo que no a la continuación de
pinochet en el poder y ahora lo que
estamos votando es justamente cambiar la
constitución y que de manera
participativa inclusiva en que la
ciudadanía elija en democracia aquellos
representantes para dictar un nuevo
texto constitucional ahora en caso de
que gane si para modificar esta
constitución cuáles serían los pasos a
seguir y cuánto duraría de además cómo
sería el proceso para modificarla
se nos van a entregar digo se nos van a
entregarlo y yo todavía no voy a votar
se nos van a entregar dos papeletas la
primera en que nos van a preguntar se
aprobados o rechazamos el tener una
nueva constitución y al mismo tiempo se
nos va a entregar una segunda papeleta
en que nos van a preguntar cuál es el
órgano que queremos que sea el encargado
de redactar la y hay dos alternativas
una de la convención mixta lo que
significa que el 50 por ciento serían
parlamentarios actuales en ejercicios
que ellos determinaría según las fuerzas
políticas en el congreso y el otro 50%
sería elegido por la ciudadanía por
candidatos que se presentarían en
elecciones en el mes de abril de ganar
la segunda opción que se llama la
convención constitucional y el 100% de
los candidatos a los constituyentes
serían elegidos democráticamente por el
pueblo y esto sería en el mes de abril
por lo tanto tenemos una elección en el
mes de abril en el caso de la prueba
luego viene el período en que los
constituyentes deben ya empezar a
trabajarse a convención mixta sea
convención constitucional y una vez que
tengan el texto estarán se llama el
plebiscito de salida es decir nuevamente
nos van a llamar a las urnas pero esta
vez para que digamos que aceptados o no
aceptamos el texto redactado por el
órgano que estuvo a cargo durante un año
paulina muchísimas gracias por su tiempo
y por estar aquí con nosotros en france
24 que tenga usted un feliz resto de día
en su país y que pues vaya a votar lo
antes posible entonces y lo que inició
como un reclamo por el alza en el pasaje
del metro en chile rápidamente se
convirtió en un masivo movimiento que
expuso las desigualdades sociales del
país los chilenos a tener la oportunidad
de decidir si quieren o no una nueva
constitución pero lograrlo no fue fácil
fueron meses de protestas
antigubernamentales y serbios reprimidos
por las fuerzas de seguridad un período
durante el cual se documentó una serie
de violaciones a los derechos humanos
andrés meza muñoz o nos cuenta como
y llegó hasta aquí
en octubre de 2019 cientos de chilenos
se lanzaron a las calles sin saber que
un año después tendrían la oportunidad
de decidir sobre una nueva constitución
rechazaban el alza a los precios del
pasaje del metro de santiago y aunque la
medida fue retirada las protestas
continuaron y se extendieron a nivel
nacional algunas de manera pacífica y
otras derivaron en saqueos y daños en el
transporte público
porque ahora me dijo
un poderoso implacable rápidamente la
protesta se convirtió en un movimiento
que se prolongó durante meses inconforme
ante las desigualdades sociales del país
genera cambios profundos profundos desde
la educación la salud las pensiones
todos
el despliegue de la fuerza para contener
el estallido social puso al presidente
sebastián piñera en la lupa de la
comunidad internacional señalando lo de
ser el responsable de violaciones de
derechos humanos el 30 de noviembre de
2019 amnistía internacional había
contabilizado más de 300 lesiones
oculares por balas de goma y al 6 de
diciembre la oficina de derechos humanos
de la onu documentaba 28 mil detenciones
entre las cuales había denuncias de
torturas y violencia sexual
la crisis obligó al gobierno a dar paso
a la creación de una nueva carta magna y
reemplazar a través de un referéndum la
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet
la consulta estaba programada para el 26
de abril pero el brote de kobe 19 no
sólo provocó su aplazamiento sino que
también ahogó en gran medida las
protestas la palabra plebiscito tiene
gran peso en chile en 1988 el pueblo
votó para sacar a pinochet y devolver al
país a la democracia ahora los chilenos
buscan aprovechar esta oportunidad para
cimentar la igualdad y borrar una oscura
mancha del que hasta hace unos meses era
uno de los países más estables de
américa latina' es ver a partir de las
20 horas bogotá quito lima en especial
donde les llevaremos todas las
incidencias del voto y analizaremos el
contexto social e histórico de chile con
invitados especiales y nuestra
corresponsal en santiago patricia luna
vamos ahora a eeuu donde los candidatos
a la presidencia de donald trump y joe
biden centran sus últimos esfuerzos para
captar los votos de los llamados estados
pendular es el presidente tumbó todo de
forma anticipada en florida y visitó
tres de estos estados y por su parte el
demócrata joe biden compartió el
protagonismo de la jornada con el ex
presidente barack obama conectamos ahora
con nuestro corresponsal en miami
antonio el si anthony buen día a nueve
días para estas elecciones los
pronósticos prevén una participación
multitudinaria como es el ambiente en
florida donde continúa el voto
anticipado
y qué tal muy buenos días raúl pues lo
cierto es que sí que en los centros de
votación hay muchísima gente ahora mismo
no hay se han dispersado un poco las
multitudes porque está lloviendo pero sí
que el flujo constante de votantes en
los centros de votación especialmente
aquí en florida es algo habitual en todo
el estado por eso a muchos aseguran que
se podrían batir récords de
participación incluso superar los 150
millones de votantes principalmente
porque ya han votado 55 millones de
personas tanto por correo o de forma
anticipada en todo eeuu eso representa
casi el 40 por ciento de todo el
electorado que votó en 2016 tal y como
apuntaba el presidente barack obama
estuvo de hecho aquí en la ciudad de
miami pues intentando a cautivar el voto
especialmente de las minorías
afroamericanos y latinos que pueden ser
clave también para estas elecciones
mientras que el presidente de donald
trump hizo su
ejerció su derecho al voto anticipado en
webs por la ciudad donde él está
registrado
anthony co usted lo dije florida es
clave entonces en esta elección pero no
es el único estado le pregunto que otros
están en la mira de las campañas y
además cuáles son los planes de los
candidatos para hoy domingo
si de hecho una de las cosas que tienen
en la mira especialmente el partido
demócrata es no perder a aquellos
estados en los que se confiaba en un
principio que se iban a ganar eso pasó
en 2016 cuando hillary clinton perdió
estados clave como wisconsin y
pensilvania michigan por eso la campaña
demócrata está haciendo especial
atención se está poniendo especial
atención a esos estados para asegurarse
que van a convertirse en estados azules
por lo tanto van a conseguir los votos
electorales necesarios para que joe
biden pueda sumar y llegar eventualmente
a la casa blanca mientras tanto también
el partido republicano también está muy
pendiente de esos votos
y estaremos también muy pendientes de
cómo evoluciona esta jornada electoral
así es antoni gracias entonces por la
información que tengo usted y el resto
de día y en noticias de venezuela el
líder opositor leopoldo lópez llegaría a
madrid españa para reencontrarse con su
familia luego de que ayer búlgara la
custodia que el gobierno de nicolás
maduro mantenía a las afueras de la
embajada de españa en caracas donde
lópez permanecía refugiado desde hace
varios meses tras haber escapado del
arresto domiciliario dejemos que sea
nuestra corresponsal en la capital
venezolana herminia fernández que nos dé
los últimos detalles sobre este caso
el gobierno de nicolás maduro continúa
sin pronunciarse hasta este momento
sobre la salida del país de leopoldo
lópez líder opositor del partido
voluntad popular familiares de lópez y
seguros la oposición aseguran que
arribará hoy domingo a españa aún no
está claro cómo fue su escape cabe
resaltar que la residencia del embajador
en españa en caracas donde estuvo
recluido lópez por más de un año estaba
custodiada por el servicio de
inteligencia bolivariano sebin hasta
ahora sólo se han detenido a la mujer
que le llevaba la comida y el vigilante
de la casa del embajador español el
líder del partido voluntad popular se
pronunció por las redes sociales y
aseguró que la decisión de irse no fue
sencilla pero que el país cuenta con él
para dar la lucha desde cualquier
espacio comentó sin agregar cuál es su
ubicación actual que como siempre desde
las calles o en una cárcel militar o
siendo perseguido su tiempo y energía
será para lograr la conquista de la
libertad aún se está a la espera de las
reacciones del gobierno de maduro que
organizado para el día de hoy un
simulacro electoral
las elecciones parlamentarias del 6 de
diciembre donde se ha negado a
participar la oposición
a continuación otras noticias destacadas
aquí en france 24 en españa se espera la
comparecencia del presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez que podría
anunciar un nuevo estado de alarma que
se extendería hasta abril después de que
varios gobiernos autónomos solicitaron
al ex al ejecutivo central la aprobación
de este instrumento para endurecer las
restricciones de movilidad y combatir
así el avance del cobi 19
colombia alcanzó este sábado de la marca
del millón de contagios de kobe 19 siete
meses y medio después de la llegada al
país de la pandemia que también deja 30
mil muertos y una crisis económica y
social según el gobierno del país ha
tenido picos por regiones en diferentes
momentos lo que permite focalizar las
estrategias según las necesidades de
cada región
francia bate récord de contagios por
tercer día consecutivo este sábado el
país registró 45 mil 422 nuevos
positivos es además uno considerable
aumento con respecto al día anterior
cuando la nación reportó 42 mil 32 casos
cifras que evidencian la escalada
constante de las últimas semanas
y los llamados a boicotear productos
franceses están aumentando en el mundo
árabe-musulmán después de la promesa del
presidente de manuel macrón el jueves en
el funeral del profesor decapitado de no
renunciar a la publicación de las
caricaturas de mahoma más en el
siguiente informe
200 personas furiosas marchan hacia la
residencia del embajador francés en la
ciudad de java israel de mayoría árabe
en sus pancartas piden la defensa del
profeta mahoma despreciado según ellos
por el presidente majo
protestamos contra la política del
gobierno francés el gobierno que
perjudica a los 1.500 millones de
musulmanes del mundo el gobierno que
alienta a perjudicar a las profetas un
gobierno sin respeto en el objeto de
subir a esta frase de manuel mccomb
pronunciada el jueves en la sorbonne
durante el homenaje al profesor de
historia sanmiguel patxi uno bueno no
renunciaremos a las caricaturas a los
dibujos aunque otros se echen atrás si
todos joaquín con estos comentarios en
referencia a las caricaturas de mahoma
el jefe de estado ha causado una
indignación de parte del mundo musulmana
en egipto turquía argelia líbano los
llamados a boicotear los productos
franceses han sido transmitidos en las
redes sociales en qatar y kuwait varias
cadenas de supermercados han retirado
mercancías francesas de sus estados
otra atmósfera en la franja de gaza
donde un puñado de manifestantes
quemaron retratos de mayor mac con el
sábado por la noche
así las cosas en el mundo hasta que el
informativo continúa con nosotros
[Música]